the Lakers are playing the Celtics it's
a regular season game it's not that
meaningful I think the game is tied at
the end of the fourth quarter and LeBron
is driving for a layup he clearly gets
fouled they don't call it he flips the
[__] out melts down they're complaining
about it after the game Patrick Beverly
which this is very funny but he like
grabs a camera and shows it to a ref
before overtime and shows them that they
missed a foul and then he gets a
technical called on the greatest attack
which is super funny that's super funny
God bless him but then 100 there's no
way the picture's even taken yeah
Anthony he's just pointing at a blank
one thousand percent Anthony Davis is
complaining afterward that we're getting
screwed over blah blah blah and first of
all Lebron travels before he doesn't
before he gets fouled they all travel
it's like four steps it's a lot so if we
want to be so technical about it but
also you're in 11th place out of 12.
yeah which means you're not even in you
know the NBA has a play in game to be
the last seed in the playoffs they're
not even in that so to act like this is
Injustice that's costing us the season
you've sucked all year LeBron went to
the Lakers I said this when he went to
the Lakers he's calling it in in terms
of getting more championships he got one
I'm surprised that's it he's not getting
any more you made this decision the
team's not good for us to make such a
big deal about an 11th Place team
getting a bad call it's just so [__]
annoying but is LeBron won a
championship with the Lakers yeah during
the pandemic went bubble oh the bubble
joint yeah it was with the Lakers yeah
yeah
oh yeah so he got his when you're in
this game and like you're losing you're
like hey I'm about to put it all in the
line for my team um he put up like how
many points this game like something
crazy
he's putting the whole team on his back
at 40 years old he's like yo I'm gonna
do it and then the last minute you have
a chance to win if you're a team you're
not thinking of the grand scheme like
yeah you could be thinking full
perspective would be like you know what
basketball doesn't really matter in the
long run anyway I know he's playing he's
like I have a chance to win it for my
team oh no no akka's not reacting to
LeBron's reaction he's reacting to the
internet's reaction oh I'm sorry I
thought you were saying LeBron you
should be upset he should be furious I
completely understand
I understand being upset and complaining
after the game you're complaining if one
player after the game was like yo it's
also on us for being the 11th [__]
seed and not even really sniffing the
playoffs at all that makes sense I would
be like okay yeah time to calm down
like even that guy you saw the Bengals
game that one player hit Patrick Mahomes
out of bounds and that's how they got
the field though Joseph osai they're in
the locker room on their way in one of
his teammates is like yo he's not even
that good he's not gonna be here next
year fume and mad he apologized
afterwards it's a shitty thing to do but
In the Heat of the Moment you're upset
whatever you calm down and you be
reasonable they still haven't calmed
down they're still talking about this
the internet the Lakers only I can get
over this [__] but don't you feel like
there's a pattern though sorry I didn't
make it no no I just lately they have
been saying that they're big they're
getting a bunch of bad calls and that's
why they're losing games okay but you're
also the Lakers so historically you've
gotten a lot of good calls you probably
have championships that you should not
have very used
nobody goes you know what we've gotten a
lot of good calls we deserve some bad
ones now sure that's fine but this the
fan reaction I hear if Lakers fans being
like this is rigged it's rigged the
emotional reaction for the Laker sense
eventually calm I hear Cowboys fans do
it eventually you calm down right
Cowboys fans are like the league is
rigged really you think they want the
Dallas Cowboys out of the playoffs yeah
yeah they do think the NFL who cares
about money over everything is like
let's take the most valuable team on
Earth knock them out for what same with
the Lakers calls are gonna generally go
in your favor as the Lakers you got a
bunch of bad calls recently okay you
still are the 11th seed those good calls
go your way you're what ninth okay big
deal like I just it's just shut the [__]
up with all this and the internet making
such a big deal about it a week later is
crazy I don't know if I've ever seen a
regular season game get responded to
like this ever that's a good point yeah
I thought it was like a playoff I was
looking it up I was like what has
happened I think this is just
frustration it's like their team sucks
they know their team sucks and then
here's an easy opportunity for them to
act like the world is against them you
know and I think that's just really what
it is like hey let me just funnel all my
frustration for the fact that like
LeBron is having an incredible season
but he's not at the point where he can
make his teammates as good as he used to
yeah and I think that's just the reality
like there was a time where LeBron
LeBron took bums to the finals his first
Finals with the Cavs do you remember
that yeah and his last finals with the
Cavs bumps I mean like so something has
happened where he can still throw up 46
points completely dominant on the
offensive end probably get triple
doubles doubles no problem but he can't
make the other guys as good as he used
to yeah and I think this happened even
to Kobe later in his career it happens
to guys where they can still get the
buckets but they can't make the other
guys very similar to what's happened to
Brady in the NFL he's still really
[__] good but he can't just Elevate
the Bucks by himself yeah football it's
harder there's more players but yeah he
used to kind of just Elevate the team
we're gonna get we're gonna do well
we're gonna be above 500 at least with
me and now he can't quite do that and
LeBron is in the same place you've
slipped a little bit you're good for a
game winner too for a season for a vet
like LeBron like you're doing too much
yes that's too much and you're 40.
that's too much at the end of the game
after this call like he's the way he
reacts on the ground for a while like
I'm in so disbelief I can't even like
stand up like I get the frustration I
think he's milking it you don't you
don't act like this maybe you shouldn't
but like anyone that doesn't understand
how he feels I'm like you never wanted
to win as bad as he wants to win again
if he wanted to win he would have gone
like historic rival this is like the
Celtics regular season in Boston 55.
still okay so here's I'm gonna give I'm
just gonna say something okay with uh
one of the things about Jordan and the
whole documentary basically was harping
on this was that he could give a hundred
percent in everything it could be
practice it could be a game it didn't
matter what the [__] it is you're
playing ping pong you're throwing coins
along the carpet you were going 100
[__] percent and
if we're saying that LeBron cares about
about basketball he truly is invested in
the sport right
and he gave 100 and it didn't go his way
then this is a justifiable reaction
right this is the only thing that he
cares about he's Furious if he just
walks on off the court like it's no big
deal okay then he just didn't really
care about what happened in that game
if it's Jordan and we're watching the
documentary they don't lose this game in
overtime
you know what I mean like Jordan he's
getting the call
I think LeBron historically gets more
calls than he doesn't if it's Jordan
he's getting the call
maybe again I also think if you cared
that much about winning you wouldn't
have gone to La you wouldn't have signed
an extension last year when it's clear
they got no prospects and your second
best player can't stay healthy I
understand what you're saying like I
think you're you're making the argument
that like he was making more of like a
lifestyle move and maybe yeah always
career move by going to La that being
said I don't I don't think that exists
in like uh I don't think we exist in a
world where it's either he cares about
winning or he doesn't yeah and you're
also talking really big picture yeah I
played in my [__] pick up soccer
games that we lost and I was like
heartbroken yeah I do it all the time
even with basketball like a game that
means nothing it doesn't mean anything
at all but in that moment you're like
holy [__] I want to give this everything
and be so frustrated if you lost on a
last second shot you missed the layup so
I can understand this especially with
historic rivalry between the Lakers and
the Celtics we can understand him being
frustrated all I'm saying is he was
melodramatic here a little bit like
you're milking it a bit I understand
being upset I'll give you a lot of room
this is like kind of crazy but afterward
I think you can calm down and as a
leader be like yo this game is way
bigger than one bad call I think that's
a decent like as a leader I don't think
you necessarily should do that but I do
understand the feeling I have a serious
question though like What if after this
game when the Lakers lost the Hollywood
Sign lit up in green
that would be crazy that'd be awesome
right that's really cool that's fine
that's a really funny thing to say yeah
that's a hilarious comment big thoughts
that building